today I want to talk to you about a
topic that has become very controversial
in the last few days in the United
States should doctors and scientists
debate anti-vaxxers this is a question
that's been raised by many people in
general in the wake of the covid-19
pandemic but in addition to that more
recently we have seen an argument take
place significantly happening on social
media between people like Joe Rogan and
Elon Musk and folks like Dr Peter Hotes
who
um is a doctor and works on vaccines on
the one hand there's the argument that
doctors and scientists should not engage
in debates with anti-vaxxers because
when a doctor or a scientist debates an
anti-vaxxer they legitimize and lend
their credibility to an anti-vaxxer for
a position that doesn't actually deserve
legitimacy and credibility this is the
position of Dr Peter Hotes he's a doctor
a vaccine expert professor at the Baylor
College of Medicine and he has
frequently been targeted by anti-vaxx
harassment campaigns and even threats
Hotes says debating anti-vaxxers is a
losing proposition they're not
interested in facts or evidence they
want to spread fear and doubt and when
you engage with them in a supposed
debate you play into their hands you
give them a platform to reach more
people with their dangerous lies and
that it shouldn't be done Dr Peter Holtz
has also says that debating anti-vaxxers
from a practical standpoint is a waste
of time and a waste of resources because
there's real work that can be done
educating the public explaining the
benefits of vaccination and he says
instead of debating anti-vaxxers what
doctors and scientists should do is just
focus on communicating with people who
are hesitant about vaccines they're
unsure about vaccines they don't have
all of the information address their
concerns with empathy and respect and
that that's a much better use of time
and resources than debating anti-vaxxers
okay that's one side on the other hand
there are those who say doctors and
scientists should debate anti-vaxxers
now some of the people saying that are
the anti-vaxxers but even people who
accept the science and understand the
science of vaccines will sometimes say
no the doctors and the scientists should
debate the anti-vaxxers because when
they do that they can assuming the
doctors and scientists are correct they
will expose the flaws and the errors of
the anti-vaxxers they will potentially
persuade followers of the anti-vaxxers
to change their minds and to come to the
side of science and reason and I've
heard Joe Rogan make this argument he's
a popular podcast host and comedian he's
been accused by some of spreading
anti-vax misinformation and he says
listen the anti-vaxx movement has
followers already there's no downside to
debating them doctors and scientists who
are confident in their arguments and
that the facts are on their side can
actually do some good when the doctors
and scientists ignore or avoid the
anti-vaxxers they miss an opportunity
to challenge them and to show why they
are wrong and Joe Rogan also says that
when you debate anti-vaxxers you're
respecting their freedom of speech and
expression you're not participating in
censoring or silencing them which only
makes them more defiant or rebellious if
nobody is going to talk to them it will
make them more defiant and rebellious so
instead of dismissing anti-vaxxers as
crazy or stupid try to understand where
they're coming from what motivates them
to reject vaccines and meet them head on
and convince them with the facts that
potentially will win out
where am I on this issue I actually
don't think there is a simple or
definitive answer about whether doctors
and scientists should debate
anti-vaxxers and I'll explain why and I
will say one other thing before I delve
more deeply into this in general when it
comes to debates the person who wins
is most often just like more charismatic
or a better Communicator it's not
necessarily the person who's factually
correct and I think that that's a really
important thing to understand unless
it's opinions right we're just like okay
these are just opinions about what movie
is good or what food is good different
scenario when we're talking about
factual stuff where there is a truth
about vaccines
we have to remember that in general with
debate the better Communicator the more
articulate or charismatic person often
wins and you might be a scientist with
all the facts on your side but you just
might not be good in a so-called debate
format and that is something that has to
be considered as well okay
if you were talking about debating
vaccines in front of an audience that's
mostly people already convinced about
vaccines or supportive of vaccines then
I don't think it's really worth the time
to debate anti-vaxxers because you're
basically preaching to the choir you've
got a you've got a pro-vaccine audience
you debate an anti-vaxxer you do great
you haven't convinced anyone that
scenario seems like a waste of time
instead I would try to encourage people
to spread the word and advocate for
vaccination if you've got an audience of
people who are mostly undecided or
conflicted about vaccines then it might
make sense to consider debating
anti-vaxxers and I do think in those
situations doctors and scientists could
reach a key group of people
who might benefit from hearing both
sides of the argument assuming you have
charismatic and articulate people from
from medicine and science doctors and
scientists could appeal to the audience
and show them why vaccines are safe and
effective in addition to this if the
format is a structured debate
clear rules and criteria it benefits
those with the fact on their side which
in this case is doctors and scientists
and doctors and scientists who might shy
away from these insane sort of like kill
stream type insane Bonkers debates where
people just shout over each other that
doesn't seem like a good idea if you
have a more formal structured format
with a good moderator that also benefits
the side with the facts on their hands
and you're able to refute anti-vaxxers
with facts and data I think that's good
chaotic and formal debate without rules
and standards I think it's not a good
scenario in which the debate
anti-vaxxers uh you'd have you you'd
have uh you'd be at a disadvantage in
that sort of a scenario and it's better
not to get dragged into that so the
answer to should doctors and scientists
debate anti-vaxxers depends on a lot of
things it depends on what is the format
how serious or structured is the debate
who's in the audience what's the point
and what else could those doctors and
scientists be doing with their time as
usual these issues are not black and
white but I want to hear from you let me
know in a comment let me know in an
email what do you think about this core
question should medicine and science
debate anti-vaxxers or does it lend them
The credibility
and legitimacy that they should not be
given we'll take a quick break and be
back with much more right after this if
you or one of your parents is starting
to lose your hearing you're not alone
about 48 million Americans have hearing
loss and only one in five people who
would benefit from using a hearing aid
are actually using one our sponsors MD
hearing create FDA registered
rechargeable hearing aids that cost a
fraction of what you typically pay for
example MD hearing's new Neo model costs
less than 10 percent of what those
marked up hearing aids are being sold
for at most hearing clinics and the Neo
is MD hearings smallest hearing aid ever
no one will even know that it's there I
have a close family friend who uses MD
hearing and loves it she said it
performs better than any hearing aid
that she's used and it's far less
noticeable MD hearing even offers a
45-day risk-free try file with a 100
percent money back guarantee so you can
buy with confidence and they have a
special deal for my audience when you
buy a pair of hearing aids you'll get
them for just 149.99 each plus they'll
include a free extra charging case go to
mdhearing.com and use the code Pacman
the link is down below